all right let's go to the phones for the
first time in 2019 and see what's on
people's minds 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 why
don't we start with where do we start
let's maybe start with the 6 4 6 area
code caller from 6 4 6
who's this where are you calling from
what's on your mind today hi dude this
is on Dominique I've called this one I'm
the French girl from New York City
living in Oklahoma what's going on and
okay I just wanted to ask you something
I've I'm sure you've noticed this too
when I look at Canada and Europe whether
it be my country France or Scandinavia
England or even New Zealand and
Australia they tend to be like social
democracies with a bit of some programs
that are democratic socialist programs
you know like in Germany they have
cooperatives why is it that in those
countries the politicians work realizing
that if you have an inflation rate
people should be paid up that inflation
rate so that they don't start and they
don't struggle and they can come to work
and be healthy why is it better American
politics and American politicians seem
to view this whole political system in
the United States as a get rich scheme
well they see do they see it as a get
rich scheme I mean in other words they
have benefited from it and so they see
it as having work to their advantage but
I think that that's kind of the problem
which is if they saw it as a quote get
rich scheme for everybody and if it
actually worked for everybody maybe that
would actually be so bad but the problem
is it's for their self enrichment oh
right you know how could you have look
if you pay people properly $15 an hour
16 dollars an hour or depending on the
region in the USA where they're
depending on the inflation rate of that
state in that city if you have happy
workers they will work better they will
be more productive and they will make
you more money but for some reason in
the United States there's this attitude
and
with brazil's election I'm sure this
lunatic has the same attitude you know
brushing over whatever his name is the
idea is to keep people repressed and
struggling and suffering you know you
got to make it on your own and it's not
you you know even if you pay taxes it
doesn't matter you're a lazy bum you're
trying to live off the government
so you're basically you should just work
and pay taxes to make them rich yeah
yeah but at the same time they say that
they want to lower taxes but at the same
time they depend on those taxes to fund
the system which has allowed them to to
succeed in their self-enrichment yeah
it's a vicious circle Dominique thank
you great to hear from you in the new
year I appreciate it